[Music]
how do we explain the unexplainable this
question has inspired numerous myths
religious practices and scientific
inquiries but Zen Buddhist practicing
throughout China from the 9th to 13th
century asked a different question why
do we need an explanation for these
monks blindly seeking answers was a vice
to overcome and learning to accept the
mysteries of existence was the true path
to enlightenment but fighting the urge
to explain the unexplainable can be
difficult so to help practice living
with these mysteries the meditating
monks used a collection of roughly 1700
the wildering and ambiguous
philosophical fault experiments called
coeds the name originally kun an in
Chinese translates to public record or
case but unlike real-world court cases
Cowen's were intentionally
incomprehensible they were surprising
surreal and frequently contradicted
themselves on the surface they contained
a proverb about the Zen Buddhist
monastic code such as living without
physical or mental attachments avoiding
binary thinking and realizing one's true
Buddha nature but by Framing those
lessons as illogical anecdotes
they became tests to help practicing
monks learn to live with ambiguity and
paradox by puzzling through these
confusing cases meditating monks could
both internalize and practice Buddhist
teachings hopefully they would let go of
the search for one true answer and
trigger a spiritual breakthrough since
these are intentionally unexplainable it
will be misguided to try and decipher
these stories ourselves but like the
monks before us we can puzzle over them
together and investigate just how
resistant they are two simple
explanations consider this Cohen
illustrating the practice of no
attachment to monks tanzen and Aikido
are travelling together down a muddy
road ahead they see an attractive
traveller unable to cross the muddy path
tanzen politely offers his help carrying
the traveler on his back across the
street and placing her down without a
word Aikido was shocked
according to monastic law monks were not
supposed to go near women let alone
touch a beautiful stranger after miles
of walking Aikido could no longer
restrain himself
how could you carry that woman tanzen
smiled I left for traveler there are you
still carrying her like all currents
this story has numerous interpretations
but one popular reading suggests that
despite never having physically carried
the traveler Aikido broke monastic law
by mentally clinging to the woman this
type of conflict examining the gray area
between the letter of the law and the
spirit of the law was common in currents
in addition to exploring ambiguity
currents often ridiculed characters
claiming total understanding of the
world around them one such example finds
three months to vaiting a temple flag
rippling in the wind the first monk
refers to the flag as a moving banner
while the second monk insists that they
are not seeing the flag move but rather
the wind blowing they argue back and
forth until finally a third monk
intervenes it is not the flag moving nor
the wind blowing but rather the movement
of your minds one interpretation of this
Cohen plays on the supposed wisdom of
the arguing monks but first asserting
the importance of the observable world
the second favoring deeper knowledge we
can infer from that world but each monks
commitment to his own answer blinds him
to the others insight and in doing so
defies an essential Buddhist ideal
abolishing binary thinking the third
monk identifies our conflict as a
perceptual one both arguing monks failed
to see the larger picture of course all
these interpretations only hint at how
to wrestle with these Cowen's neither
the wisdom from practicing monks before
us nor the supposedly wise characters in
these stories can resolve them for you
that's because the purpose of these
cones isn't reaching a simple solution
it's the very act of struggling with
these paradoxical puzzles which
challenge our desire for resolution and
our understanding of understanding
itself want to try your hand at some
puzzles that do have resolutions check
out our riddles playlist and get solving
[Music]